okay okay um guys guys we're playing
this game at call the Eleanor's what is
a hallway I guess and it's a game where
I don't know you just explore find the
places okay so but just dude oh very
abrupt very oh this will cam very nice
okay okay all right all right I got gut
gut okay yeah I say look very much like
my desk hello ma'am all right scary
jesus [ __ ] kids I can cats and up
that's a hunt assess all right nice a
nice um I miss the sound of the oceans
and it's fine Oh
oh hey I hear you bet come out and face
me like a man hey if I get a [ __ ] lamb
don't pretend like you can't get out
here okay jaysus matter were like a
night around me
ah
ah
things that guy too well in here but I
got in here ma'am ma'am oh ok oh ok ok
it's geek out up
all right a second maybe a little scared
here I got [ __ ] a sucker oh [ __ ] stuck
in a [ __ ] around you know what
happens that's very quiet yeah what it
means good quiet man's up charge
how
yeah oh uh uh ma'am I guess
yeah ok ok I'm ok well that's siding
fine i'll be a joyous
Oh